my name is Bonnie but he called me big
and even though my partner agent here I
could still have the W qqqq club I moved
around a lot as a child like a lot I was
always just really interested in
photography and video and audio
recording I'm just sort of documenting
everything I became interested in mobile
technology specifically to me it
represents an accessible form of media
production so I came to MIT as a
graduate student in part of Media
Studies and as such I was assigned to be
a researcher at the Center for futures
of the Canadian Centre for future Civic
media is that is in a certain way the
heart of the business because it enables
us to work with the Civic process you
know media is really central to how we
see ourselves now we connect to other
people the latest product I ran was it's
called M generations mom had a
generation of people who came to this
country this is me writing and then the
next generation will use mobile
technologies every day my name is Mary
Adam and we had two adults as well one
of them would drive from group home to
group home he worked as a social worker
so he's always on the road and he would
film in the car all the time I do travel
like a hundred miles every day seeing my
clients was cutting videos downs the
other members of the group were
teenagers watch his footage and say oh
look yeah I didn't know he drives all
around the state for work all the time
here and now he's driving in it's
midnight he must work all the time but
Audubon chose not to supply these kids
with high-end video cameras but rather
to equip them or have them draw on the
cameras that they carry with them every
day in the form of a cell phone what's
terrific about that is that students
become active viewers of the world
around them they are potentially
always all the time documentary
filmmakers chemistry class watching what
their peers were filming really got
people weren't sighted I think to go
back and film more about their lives at
the end when we showed the final video
to the whole congregation of almost 300
members of this church that I think was
very embarrassing for a lot of people
but it was also hopefully a moment of
pride of like yeah look this is me this
is my life and now you know a little bit
more about me I think the main thing is
that it's never about the technology
ever and of course we at MIT have to
remind ourselves that all the time we
always have a new shiny technology but
it's never about the technology it's
always about the social processes behind
it how does it get used what impact does
it have on human beings
[Music]